alberto guist aus dem tennis desaster
durch lohn seit gestern zurück in seiner
heimat
ein winziges dorf im süden von rumänien
seine reise dauerte fünf tage mit dem
zug dann mit dem bus er ist heilfroh
wieder zu hause zu sein
[Musik]
ich arbeite seit zwölf jahren immer
wieder in deutschland aber was ich in
den vergangenen drei monaten erlebt habe
war die härteste erfahrung meines lebens
einen seiner kollegen bei turniers hat
es erwischt
er sitzt mit zehn anderen in diesem haus
in oelde fest alle sind infiziert die
männer sind krank geworden und
umgefallen arbeiter die positiv getestet
wurden waren trotzdem bei der arbeit so
lange sie sich gut fühlten hat es kein
gekümmert abstand am band war bei
turniers nicht möglich berichten die
arbeiter nun kämpfen fünf von ihnen auf
die intensivstation um ihr leben
dass ministerpräsident laschet rumänen
und bulgaren ursprünglich selbst für den
ausbruch des virus verantwortlich
gemacht hat empört viele arbeiter
denn während es in deutschland im april
knapp 130000 fälle gab waren es in
rumänien nur rund 7000 wir haben es
sicher nicht mitgebracht corona war ja
vorher schon in deutschland albert hugo
und seine frau gehörten zu den ersten
die im april nach deutschland geflogen
worden waren um bei der ernte zu helfen
dafür ließen sie acht kinder zurück wir
mussten ihnen einiges versprechen damit
sie aufhören zu weinen
eines möchte ein fahrrad ein anderes
süßigkeit auf die erntehelfer initiative
der bundesregierung hin reißt alberto
nach deutschland obwohl deutschland
damals ein chor ohne risiko land ist
abstand am flughafen es wird fieber
gemessen auf den tafeln die ziele in
deutschland
dann schickt er uns diese bilder aus dem
flieger dichtes gedränge dort
er landet auf einem spargelhof auch dort
kein abstand nicht in den bussen die sie
zum feld bringen nicht in den
wohncontainern in denen sie leben statt
zwei männern leben vier in einem
container und immer droht corona
spargelhof hat mich dann vor die tür
gesetzt es war eine demütigung
ich habe auf der straße geschlafen und
gehungert alberto flüchtet sich zu der
firma bei der er schon seit jahren
anheuert turniers hier gerät er vom
regen in die traufe
ich hatte echt angst dass ich krank
mit 50 kilo fleisch im arm wie willst du
da auf abstand achten
einmal sagte ich zu meiner chefin ich
bin krank ich kann nicht mehr
und sie sagte du darfst nicht aufhören
alberto ist jetzt zu hause seine frau
allerdings ist immer noch bei turniers
meine frau wollte dort bleiben wir
brauchen das geld
wir müssen die kinder groß elisabeth
gewann saß im selben flieger wie alberto
gogo auch sie sollte in deutschland bei
der ernte helfen
natürlich habe ich angst vor corona aber
das kann uns auch hier erwischen wir
treffen sie jetzt wieder auch sie ist
zurück in rumänien
jetzt passt sie auf die enkelkinder auf
für ihre familie tut sie alles auch wenn
das bedeutet sie zu verlassen
für ihre familie gingen sie vor zehn
jahren zum ersten mal nach deutschland
ich hatte schulden und deshalb musste
ich nach deutschland zum arbeiten
ich wollte meinen kindern eine bessere
zukunft geben entschuldigung das geht
mir immer noch
auch sie gerät in deutschland ins corona
chaos der hof auf dem sie erdbeeren
pflücken soll geht pleite
die arbeiter protestieren weil man sie
nicht bezahlt rechtsanwälte sagen ihr
mach deine arbeit fertig und geh nach
hause
das war respektlos wir wollen wie
menschen behandelt werden
rumänen machen die ganze arbeit
behandelt uns auch vernünftig selbst im
eigenen dorf sind die wanderarbeiter
unbeliebt die leute denken wir hätten
viel geld aber dieses geld verdienen wir
mit tränen und harter arbeit
ich vermisse meine kinder und enkel
wahnsinnig manchmal mache ich ein
videotelefonat mit ihnen aber das ist
teuer
ich muss meine daten gut einteilen damit
ich ihre gesichter oft genug sehen kann
im monat
von solchen schicksalen hörte nicolai
schäfer mutter ständig ist mitglied im
europäischen parlament kümmert sich dort
um die probleme von rumänischen
wanderarbeitern
wie viele der zeit zurückkehren ohne
getestet zu werden ist unbekannt
ich glaube leidet aus weniger jetzt
kommen werden weil gesundheit ist das
allerwichtigste und wenn es solche fälle
gibt dann jetzt vielleicht an einem
arbeitsmangel geben und ich erfahre
jetzt von dem rumänischen mitarbeiter
dass viele von denen jetzt zurückkehren
wenn es auch wenn sie geld verlieren
elisabeth wird wieder nach deutschland
gehen um dort zu arbeiten auch wenn ihr
das viel abverlangt meine kinder haben
jetzt ein besseres leben ich bin froh
dass ich das geschafft habe
das erste was alberto nach seiner
rückkehr tut er fährt in den baumarkt
vom geld das er in deutschland verdient
hat renoviert er jetzt sein haus
ob er corona hat weiß er nicht zwölf
jahre lang hat er in deutschland
gearbeitet doch nachdem corona chaos
reicht es ihm
ich will nicht mehr zurück nach
deutschland
nicht mal wenn das alles vorbei ist so
was habe ich in den 44 jahren meines
lebens noch nicht erlebt das sind die
erlebnisse von elisabetta und alberto
die mitten in der korona krise nach
deutschland kamen um bei der ernte zu
helfen und im schlachthof zu schuften
[Musik]